[Music]
our planet has survived the billions of
years of catastrophic events that made
it the world we live on now but one day
there will be an event so disastrous
that it will destroy this floating Rock
and end this experiment known as
Humanity after the lengthy number of
possibilities we've narrowed down our
list to the top seven Earth chattering
events would we be sucked into an
endless void
could a second star appear and Fry our
planet or is death waiting just below
Earth's crust whether it was the breakup
of Pangia or the meteor that took out
the dinosaurs Earth has been through
more than one apocalyptic event these
events changed our planet's geography
while ushering in new ages for the life
forms that followed and that's us
usually been at the expense of the
creatures who were already here but
somewhere in our planet's future lies an
Extinction event so devastating that it
might not simply take out all of
humanity but the Earth as well and in a
matter of time our world could return to
dust so what would it take to rip apart
the Earth
completely stargazing can bring a sense
of wonder that calms your mind but that
may be over now because that shooting
star you spotted isn't here to Grant
your wish you may want a
duck hurricanes remain one of the most
deadly natural events on our planet and
they leave a trail of death and
destruction wherever they land but if an
asteroid hits an ocean with enough
enough force and heat hurricanes would
be like fluff balls compared to what
would come next a big enough asteroid
would superheat the oceans to over
49° and this could set off a massive
storm known as a
hypercane winds would move as fast as
the speed of sound and clouds would
reach Heights of up to 40 km the winds
would shoot water and aerosols into the
stratosphere destroying the ozone layer
so even if the winds didn't carry you
into space you could get fried by the
radiation on Earth's
surface this gas giant has twice the
mass of all the planets in our solar
system
combined and the gases swirling around
inside Jupiter's atmosphere are the same
material that make up the Sun but if
Jupiter became 1,000 times more massive
that distant yellow dot would wreak
havoc on our planet with that much mass
Jupiter would turn into a star since
this new star would be right in the
middle of the solar system planetary
bodies would change their orbits Earth
could get pulled in closer to Jupiter
and get scorched by the heat coming off
the former planet or even worse
gravitational forces could make our
world a rogue planet that means we'd be
sent away into space outside the solar
system endlessly roaming the universe in
search of a new home without the heat of
the sun to keep us warm the surface of
the Earth would freeze over killing all
life on our
planet
but maybe we shouldn't focus on a star
that hasn't formed yet and concentrate
on the one we have after all this ball
of gas makes life possible on our planet
but since it burns through 600 million
tons of hydrogen every second it's only
a matter of time before this power
source is used up and when that occurs
the sun's core will become saturated
with helium and begin to shrink the
increased pressure and temperature would
cause the sun to spit out massive
amounts of energy the sun's outer layers
would expand creating a deadly Heat Wave
on Earth our oceans would evaporate into
thin air and the radiation would Scorch
the planet's surface finally the sun
once The Giver of Life Would swallow up
what's left of our molten planet and if
the Sun keeps expanding our solar system
would face a new threat oh man it just
keeps getting
worse if the sun gains even more mass
before collapsing you could witness the
birth of one of the most mysterious
forces in the universe a black hole the
product of a Dying Stone are the
gravitational pull of this void can rip
apart other stars and planets right now
the sun is too small to create one of
these catastrophes but if a black hole
appears in front of Earth the uneven
gravitational pull would start deforming
the planet earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions would break out all over the
planet and as you come closer to the
black hole's Event Horizon this monster
might stretch out this world like a
rubber band a black hole sucks in matter
by compressing it horizontally making it
look like a noodle we call this
spaghettification every bit of our
planet would be stretched into a string
of atoms and fed into this hungry
void do you think Earth's future
couldn't get any worse well come on this
is what if and right now 10 to 20
volcanoes are erupting across our planet
spewing Ash and gas into the
atmosphere but if every volcano on Earth
exploded at once you couldn't escape the
fumes and heat no matter where you live
rocks reaching
1,000° would travel as fast as 700
kmph with such a massive amount of
molten rock slamming onto the surface
the planet could lose its balance and
the poles could realign a thick layer of
Ash and gas would suffocate Earth and
eventually block out all the sunlight
and while the lava cools the temperature
on Earth would drastically drop sending
us into another Ice Age while this event
wouldn't necessarily end our entire
planet it would destroy any chance of
sustaining life until those clouds clear
up the earth makes one full rotation on
its axis every 23 hours 56 minutes and
4.1 seconds and it's not moving at the
same speed everywhere the rotational
speed varies depending on your distance
to the poles if you're at the the
equator it moves the fastest at a rate
of
m/s at the North or South Pole it's
moving the slowest technically it's not
moving at all this rotation makes Earth
suitable for Life the dial cycle or the
shifting between day and night helps
keep the planet at a habitable
temperature Earth's rotation is the
driving force of weather patterns even
tides are affected by the Earth's spin
so if we were to accelerate this
rotation would we completely destabilize
the
climate if you increased the rotational
speed by 0.45 m/s our days would be
shorter but only by a minute and a half
you might not even notice the change I
don't know but even with this slight
increase sea levels would Rise by
several CM or a few inches yeah the
water around the poles would migrate
toward the equator now if you increased
this acceleration to 45
m/s then a single day would be about 22
hours you'd start to feel confused
almost like jet lag we'd also need to
add a few more days to the year but for
sea levels it would be a dramatic I
change the world's oceans at the equator
would rise as much as 9 to 20 M places
like New York Venice and Mumbai would be
submerged millions of people would be
displaced now if we doubled the current
rotation speed to 920
m/s disaster would strike water would
cover everything except for the highest
mountains like kilamanjaro or the
highest Summits of the Andes satellites
orbiting the planet would be out of sync
as they need to orbit at a speed that
matches our
rotation this would disrupt
Communications television broadcasting
and military
operations and you would notice some
significant weather
changes the air would be heavy with
moisture dense fog clouds and constant
rain would be the norm in Regions near
the equator
if you keep speeding things up at some
point you could fly off the planet
that's because the centrifugal force of
the rotation would be enough to overcome
the gravity keeping you on the
surface this would happen at a speed of
7,886
m/s and you would experience reverse
rain yeah droplets of water would move
upward in the atmosphere instead instead
of falling now if you pushed the speed
to 11,000 m/s the Earth's crust would
begin to flatten at the poles and bulge
around the equator enormous earthquakes
would rattle to Planet there would be
little chance that anything on Earth
could
survive but if you were to crank the
velocity up some more brace
yourself like to the speed of light
things would get wild if the Earth
rotated at a speed of 299,792,458
the Earth is flant and stationary
rotating at this extreme speed would
distort time on Earth it would slow down
so much that it would eventually stop
you would freeze in time so hopefully
you'd be caught in a good
moment Earth could become a tiny black
hole that's because an object moving at
the speed of light has an infinite Mass
yeah nothing would be making it out of
this situation
alive a category 6 hurricane is About to
Rock New
York Category 5 is the highest
classification a storm can get these
storms have wind speeds of 252 kmph or
higher and they're
catastrophic homes get destroyed large
areas are rendered uninhabitable and the
power outages could last for weeks even
months but with the warming effects of
climate change on our oceans and
atmosphere a whole new classification
could be added to the mix Category
6 a super storm this strong would make a
category 5 storm seem like a windy walk
in the park the very first seed of this
tropical storm would form in October oob
late into hurricane season it would
start as a low pressure weather system
that creates clouds and
thunderstorms 10 days later this
tropical wave as it's known would evolve
into a tropical storm in the
Caribbean but it wouldn't stop there
after a few more days HS officially
hurricane what if and as it passes over
Jamaica and Cuba it would continue to
grow in size and force climbing from a
category 1 to three and even up to five
from New York you'd see the damage wha
if is causing in its path but you still
wouldn't worry normally these storms
curve East and out to sea before they
hit
you this time you wouldn't be so
lucky 3 weeks after it began the storm
would shatter records to become the
biggest strongest hurricane ever making
its first landfall in New Jersey it
would slam the state with wind speeds up
to 300
kmph when Hurricane Sandy made landfall
here in 2012 the wind speeds were less
than half of that and when all was said
and done Sandy caused around 2 million
people to lose power $19 billion in
damages and left 43 dead when our
Category 6 hurricane makes landfall in
New York you should expect
astronomically more damage than this the
storm would be larger in size than half
of the United States that's when the
real chaos would
begin Storm surges over 8 m would cause
rapid and dangerous flooding all over
the city from the beach es to the
streets to the tunnels without mass
evacuations Millions would be stranded
or in immediate danger of drowning water
would gush into the subway stations it
would sweep buses and cars down the
street Wastewater plants would be
impacted resulting in untreated sewage
mixing with local
waterways if you were caught outside you
would be certainly fighting for your
life powerful winds would make flying
debris a constant Hazard a category 6
storm would make the smallest objects
into deadly
projectiles especially shards of glass
from damaged skyscrapers that would Sway
in the wind like
trees if the wind managed to penetrate
your storm-proof building all that air
would make the roof and walls cave in
and that would mean even more projectile
material in the Wind
the power would go out too all of New
York City and its nearly 9 million
residents would be in total
darkness vital services such as Health
Care Transportation and communication
would be completely cut off millions of
people would be desperate for
rescue before all this is over you'd
find yourself briefly in the eye of the
storm here everything would seem calm
the pressure in the center of this storm
would be so low it would be like
standing on a mountain peak 1500 m above
sea level yeah you'd be gulping for
air finally the storm would subside on
land there would no longer be warm ocean
water to fuel it but with so much
infrastructure destroyed you'd have no
way out except by boat as as you
traveled through the flooded streets of
Manhattan you'd see the whole city
completely ruined the power would be out
in Time Square millions could lose their
homes and many would
die life on Earth has ended several
times before and it's safe to say it
will happen again think you're prepped
for these scenarios let us know in the
comments of course we based these
doomsday predictions around science and
observable facts but some things are
beyond our understanding like what if
the threat to our existence wasn't miles
underground what if it was less than 2 M
below what if there was a zombie
apocalypse well start working on your
cardio because that's a story for
another what is
[Music]
f